et après le festival coup d'état le
festival magnifique de maurepas a donc
maintenant à chevreuse consacré aux arts
de la rue à la musique au cirque
également 14 15 et 16 septembre quel est
le mot qui symbolise le mieux ce
festival c'est quoi la diversité
peut-être
diversité en fait il ya plein de mots
qui caractérisent le festival hier voilà
la convivialité
l'engagement parce que c'est quand même
un festival engagé
voilà c'est leur festival des lumières j
allais l'engagement justement qu'il ya
derrière ça festival
l'engagement déjà 2
de centaines de bénévoles je crois c'est
déjà déjà ça qui fait qu'on arrive à
faire de grandes choses avec des petits
moyens voilà l'engagement de deux
différents partenaires qui s'associent
pour voilà faire réussir à ce festival
l'engagement de groupes locaux de
groupes qui viennent un peu plus loin de
deux compagnies voilà qui qui défendent
un projet
parce qu'une association derrière qui
pilote tout ça voilà une association qui
s'appelle accueil loisirs culture donc à
chevreuse vous avez fondé ce festival en
mélangeant musique cirque arts de la rue
pourquoi mélanger tout ça c'est que
c'est complémentaire c'est quand on va
voir un petit peu tout expliquez-nous
votre volonté derrière tout ça pour quoi
l'idée l'idée c'est déjà de c'est
vraiment de faire un festival qui fédère
les comment dire les énergies positives
du local et puis voilà de pouvoir
accueillir aussi des des têtes d'affiché
d'un petit peu plus loin mais en tout
cas voilà de fédérer les gens qui ont
envie de faire des choses dans le dans
notre belle vallée de chevreuse voilà
donc ça regroupe à la fois des
plasticiens qui sont
qui sont présentes puis la seconde
édition l'idée c'est aussi de créer des
partenariats qui dure avec les
associations il ya beaucoup de musique
mais il ya aussi des arts de rue l'idée
c'est aussi de surprendre les gens de
pas voilà les cantonner à quelque chose
qui connaissent mais de pouvoir voilà au
détour d'une rue croiser une fanfare
allez un petit peu plus loin dans un
café pour écouter un des images de
l'édition 2011 justement qui s'envole à
dépasser tout ça gratuit en plus c'est
gratuit on a plus de 45 concerts et
spectacles gratuits sur le week end et
on propose le samedi soir un concert
payant sous chapiteau alors ça c'est le
seul concert qui est payé en voilà
exactement 10 euros 10 euros tarif
unique il ya un groupe notamment qui
sera présent c'est de luxe un groupe
dont on parle de plus en plus on va
regarder justement un petit extrait pour
ceux qui voudraient se rendre à ce
festival vous allez découvrir de luxe
extrait du groupe de luxe tout de suite
à
soit l'histoire
non
lux l'un des groupes qui sera présent
donc sur ce festival magnifique du côté
de chevreuse à partir de vendredi le
groupe de luxe sera présent le samedi
sur le seul rendez-vous qui est payant
tout le reste et est gratuit quels sont
les autres artistes peut-être à
découvrir est-ce que vous avez des coups
de coeur sur la programmation mais nous
il ya un artiste qui vient depuis
quelques années maintenant sur chevreuse
et alex et sa guitare et pas mal connues
dans les yvelines qui est du coin oui
tout à fait l'opposition voit sur ce
plateau il proposera son nouveau
spectacle dimanche sous le chapiteau
mais gratuitement cette fois alex et sa
guitare notamment entoure vous nous
l'avez dit 45 artistes des ateliers au
sihh s'est ouvert à tous les enfants sur
les bienvenus il ya des ateliers pour
eux spécifiques il ya beaucoup de l'idée
c'est vraiment que conçoit petits grands
puissent passer un bon moment sur le
festival
donc en plus de toute la programmation
vraiment artistiques concerts arts de
rue etc il ya un ensemble d'activités
qui sont mises en place pour les plus
jeunes mais pourquoi pas un jour où les
moins jeunes
du type alors c'est beaucoup
d'associations qui viennent proposer des
choses donc il ya des initiations
escrime tir à l'arc il ya de la grimpe
d'arbres
voilà ce genre de choses qui propose un
stand de customisation dhabi on a aussi
des activités comme trampoline élastique
équitation beaucoup d'acteurs locaux en
fait qu'ils se regroupent sur ce
festival et combien de personnes sont
attendues sur ce festival l'an passé on
était autour de 400 mille personnes ici
on peut
sonner nombreux pour battre ce record du
côté de cheuvreux sur le festival
magnifique à partir de vendredi et
jusqu'à jusqu'à dimanche voilà tous les
artistes y sont à découvrir merci d'être
venu sur le plateau nous parlions
également y ait quelques instants de ce
festival de bande dessinée c'est à
crêpière le samedi et le dimanche
invitée d'honneur claire bigard qui
étaient avec nous ce soir merci à toutes
les doses est donné par les festivals
donc du côté de crespières et du côté de
chevreuse pour la musique et les arts de
rue économie et politique c'est ainsi
que nous allons poursuivre cette édition
je vais recevoir dans un instant jean
michel fourgous ancien député ump de la
11e circonscription maire d'elancourt et
puis c'était laisse gastines qui me
rejoindra pour la chronique de l'éco
rester avec nous sur téléphiles